still plenty of time on the shot clock  man takes the baseline the stumble and  kick magruder for the lead  he's got it robbie magruder delivers a  three  a 27 three-point  shooter  this one for the tie 22 points  his first free throws of the day  missed them both rebound knocked around  nurse kitsch got a hand on it  shamit controls and it's going the other  way  with 15.5 on the clock lillard just  missed on a pair of free throws  with his team down by one and now  michael green will head to the strike  willard an 87 percent free-throw shooter  missing those  this was after the lillard miss morris  and beverly reacting  i mean patrick beverly's not playing but  he's still  enjoying himself just don't get hurt  over there pat i mean you know you're  out with an injury and now you're  falling off the  you know table there whatever it's on a  pair and  that will do it mccallum tosses up the  horn  and he cans it the clippers hand the  blazers  a big bubble blow  122 to 117